the president has put out and been very
transparent in the information he
provided so you're not winning the trust
battle I bet oneness was Germany
prepared was anyone prepared was China
prepared this week comfort zone is back
on air and like many millions of people
around the world we to social distancing
while we won't be able to interview
people face to face we can still record
via the Internet
and try to bring you the best possible
quality with that so according to
current figures the US has been the
country worst hit by the corona virus
the infection rates of skyrocketing
relative to other countries around the
world my guest this week from Washington
is the Republican national party
spokesperson Elizabeth Harrington could
president chump have done far more than
he did to stop this virus both at home
and abroad
[Music]
Elizabeth Harrington welcome to conflict
zone thank you for having me you said on
April the 19th that the president has
moved with record speed to combat the
corona virus and bring relief to
hardworking Americans but there's been
no record speed on testing for the virus
has there despite all the false
assurances that have come from the White
House we have this from your own
governor Larry Hogan from Maryland who
said the president's claim that states
have enough tests to reopen is just
absolutely false why is the president
putting out false information well
that's not true the president has put
out and been very transparent in the
information he provided in the taskforce
briefing just yesterday he showed the
5,000 different places locations across
this country where testing is available
and ready to be used by governors across
our great nation and if you look at the
speed at which President Trump has acted
it's been unprecedented this is an
amazing unprecedented situation but at
every step of the way President Trump
has made bold early decisions where
naysayers ridiculed him and accused him
of being xenophobic the World Health
Organization said it would only bring
stigma and wouldn't save lives with
travel restrictions well president
Trump's been proven correct and as dr.
Fauci has said numerous times those
travel restrictions in the very
beginning did save lives and when it
comes to testing right now we have 93%
of Americans or within 10 miles of a
testing location that's a unprecedented
achievement in a very short amount of
time when you think about what the CDC
infrastructure had in place with a
broken system that really just wouldn't
have been feasible for any any type of
virus that like this that we're facing
right now and the way we've been able to
waive regulations get the private sector
involved to have more capacity per
capita more testing in New York City by
64% than South Korea had that's an
amazing achievement and
in a matter of weeks that's very
impressive so the governor's like Larry
Hogan and other Republican governors
have Mike DeWine from Ohio for instance
he says that states simply cannot find
the materials and reagents to expand
their testing capacity and Larry Hogan
himself absolutely false he says the
president's claims are so they don't
know what they're talking about is that
right it's a lack of it's a lack of
communication on their part it is we're
talking about ramping up something
that's unbelievable in a very quick
amount of time and you're talking about
China that was a net exporter of PPE
before this pandemic and then suddenly
when they were hiding the truth from the
world what did they do they became a net
importer of PPE and have been hoarding
that so it has been a challenge across
the world to get the needed supplies and
medical devices that we needed and if
you've been watching the taskforce
briefings the task force has been
explaining at the very beginning there
was only one place to get swabs that we
could use for tests and that was from a
factory in northern Italy where they had
obviously issues of their own so it has
been there have been challenges along
the way but the really unprecedented way
to get the private sector involved the
task force talked to yesterday about a
company that was making q-tips is now
changing what they do to make swabs to
get States the resources they need and
look by and large the administration has
worked very well with these governors of
both political parties and they've
really come together to deliver for the
American people no one has gone without
a ventilator that needed one we have the
Army Corps of Engineers put building up
hospitals of 1,200 beds in a matter of
days beds that we thankfully did not
need in New York City so by and large
this has been a phenomenal achievement
and all hands on deck working with the
private sector to deliver the supplies
that we need in a fast way well you say
that but March the 7th mr. Trump told
the country
just were available to everyone anybody
that needs a test gets a test there
there they have the tests and the tests
are beautiful except that it was left to
Antony falchi the director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases to come clean on
March the 12th and tell the nation what
the president wouldn't tell them the US
was still not providing adequate testing
for the virus it's failing
he said let's admit it he said this to
Congress the idea of anybody getting
testing easily the way people in other
countries are doing it we're not set up
for that I think it should be but we're
not that's in direct contradiction to
what you've been telling me isn't it no
it's not if you look you're you can go
back in time and try to rewrite history
with facts you have now but the facts at
the time when he was at the CDC in
Atlanta how many cases did we have in
the United States a very low number so
when you're talking about anyone who
needed a test need that was available
and of course dr. Fatih has talked about
this numerous times you know what the
problem was with testing at the very
outset was that government did not have
the capability for a nationwide test we
had to go to the private sector and when
we got the private sector involved
that's led us to become the world leader
in testing so it's very convenient for
people to go back and rewrite history
but the facts at the time in early March
when we had a very limited number of
cases we were able to test people send
it to the CDC and get those results back
but guess what as the crisis changed as
the problem adapted we adapted and we
waived unnecessary ownerís regulation
that required States to send all of
their testing to be testing at the CDC
that wasn't feasible but guess what that
was what the regulations forced us to do
by waiving that and by working with the
FDA and listen to what dr. Burks has
said she has spent a lifetime ago
in service she's never seen an
administration be able to talk to the
doctors and private companies on the
front lines what they need and then
saying there's this roadblock because
government is in the way with this
regulation and this administration has
stepped up and gotten those people on
the front lines the resources they need
say that this isn't a question of
rewriting history this is recording what
people said at the time and within five
days of each other
Anthony Falchi the director of the
National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases
so something completely different than
the president namely that the testing is
failing and that's in direct
contradiction to what mr. trumpet said
five days earlier we are totally
prepared
he wasn't the US wasn't totally prepared
for this was it you you yourself
admitted you weren't prepared for it
because you didn't know it was gonna
happen was Germany prepared was anyone
prepared was China prepared and this is
this is a ridiculous hindsight rewriting
of history because the fact of the
matter is when he was at the CDC meeting
with the experts who were leading this
response this situation changes a lot in
five days you know that everyone knows
that when you have cases all of a sudden
doubling of course the situation changes
but the fact remains we've taken a
system that was not able to process the
types of capabilities that we need and
we've turned that around in a matter of
weeks and it's an impressive
accomplishment in the u.s. is now the
world leader in testing and again
let's quote dr. Falchi What did he say
on Friday testing is important but it's
not everything and so the media to
rewrite history and now after they
failed to get President Trump and say we
don't have enough ventilators and he's
you know being reckless by not giving
New York City 30,000 when that was
nowhere near what we needed now they're
saying testing testing testing we don't
have enough well the fact remains
testing is important we have the
capability
to reopen our country but what good does
a test say today that you're negative
and then tomorrow you contract the virus
it's just the media is using this to
attack the president when it's
completely uncalled-for
and they're completely rewriting history
you have doctor thought you said
attacking the president you said if you
had a process that was ongoing and you
started mitigation earlier you could
have saved lives but he noted there was
a lot of pushback about shutting things
early in the that's that's really that
is not guess what doctor foul she
clarified those comments because it was
a gotcha question or hypothetical by CNN
guess what he said the next day you are
misinterpreting what I said of course a
hypothetical of course you can go back
and say if we would have done this or we
would have done that you know what
doctor foul she said every step of the
way when we recommended mitigation when
President Trump said okay when when when
so that is when President Trump at and
said let's do 15 days to slow the spread
that's when President Trump said okay
let's do 30 more days to slow the spread
so you are totally taking doctor foul Qi
out of context it's not accurate and he
cleared this up for everyone to say and
the media attacked him for it and the
media said are you being forced to say
this really denigrating the integrity of
doctor foul Qi and I think it's really
irresponsible for people in the media to
continue try to use people who were
working 24 hours a day on this to try to
say they have bad ill motives they have
done an incredible job all working
together when the recommendations were
presented to President Trump he took
them and you know asked Nancy Pelosi
what was she doing in February she was
saying come to Chinatown she wasn't
taking this seriously
she should have been in Congress giving
relief to Americans and she's still
holding it up so don't tell me that
Republicans and
trunk haven't acted immediately and
haven't taken this seriously when we see
delay after delay after delay from
Democrats in Congress how helpful was it
with Harrington to cut the funding for
u.s. public health staff operating
inside China by two-thirds reducing
their numbers from 47 people in January
2017 to 14 by 29 thereby removing a
substantial number of the vital eyes and
ears installed in China that could have
told you that this epidemic was breaking
out hope dinah China did not help us
whatsoever so it wouldn't have really
made a difference about her who was on
the ground they kicked out journalists
they kicked out they disappeared doctors
who were sounding the alarm they along
with their allies in the corrupt World
Health Organization hid the truth about
the virus for over a month for six or
seven weeks and allowed trapped people
to travel outside of China when they
restricted travel inside their own
country it's amazing that they're trying
to shift the blame to the United States
of America when China because of their
corruption because of their secrecy
because of their deceit the entire world
is suffering because of that lack of
transparency and then lying in the World
Health Organization sandal January 14
there's no human to human transmission
of the virus that was a disgusting lie
that has caused millions the the funding
for us seen the specifics of that fact
but Democrats and the media have been
falsely accusing the president of
cutting the CDC budget and everything
else and that's just not true so I
haven't seen those details and I would
suspect that this is not accurate as
well
what it do when China is kicking out
journalists not sharing the info
nation with us human
you had an epidemiologist who was
actually inside China's own Disease
Control Agency and the funding for that
was cut last year beggars belief doesn't
it I don't think the funding was cut I
just don't I don't think that's accurate
so when job says I wish I could they
could have told us earlier what was
going on inside China well you know do
American scientists control what Chinese
labs are telling the world it's just
amazing that you're trying to blame
America for something that China they
are the ones who hid the truth about
this virus and let it escape and unleash
around the world and it's it's caused
incredible amount of pain for not just
the United States but the entire world
and it's shameful and we need to get to
the bottom of it and China needs to be
open and honest about what exactly was
going on because their lies have really
caused it's just a tremendous global
global economic plight the amount of
lives lost and it's a direct result of a
communist regime covering up their
failures and not being honest with the
world it's certainly not a fault of
America you said you didn't know this
was going to happen the intelligence
community's worldwide threat assessment
in 2019 said we assess that the United
States and the world will remain
vulnerable to the next flu pandemic or
large-scale outbreak of a contagious
disease that could lead to massive rates
of death and disability and severely
affect the world economy turns out to
have been pretty accurate doesn't it
but in 2018 you also closed the global
health security office at the National
Security Council a body whose main job
was to prepare for and prevent the kind
of pandemic that we see now that is not
true as false as Tim Morrison who headed
inter-agency in the national security
council asked him because he was in
charge of it and just and he didn't
close it they were working on this at
the National Security Council of course
they were concerned about the potential
problem but you know what was what was
the other aspects of the intelligence
community what were they what were they
warning about in early January I I tend
to remember it was all about Ukraine and
pretending that Ukraine not momentarily
pausing aid to Ukraine was our biggest
national security threat
how laughable that was then and it's
certainly laughable now what the
Democrats did wasting our time you know
what Adams intelligence when Adam Schiff
even when he was still in the minority
and representative Devin Nunez was
trying to hold a hearing on the threat
posed by China Adam Schiff hijacked
those hearings to talk about Russia so
Democrats it's very rich that there
leakers in the Intelligence Committee a
community who've been talking about
Ukraine and Russia for months are
suddenly now trying to rewrite the
script and pretend they were actually
warning about a coming pandemic it is
laughable it was in the it was in the
2019
threat assessment worldwide threat
assessment it's there what was done
about it in response to the worldwide
threat assessment you know what was done
from visit Trump signed an executive
orders president Trump sign an executive
order last summer that incentivized
government to buy America American to
bring our core manufacturing so we're
not dependent on China for the supply
chain so we're not dependent for their
medicines that is what the president has
been working on since day one and of
course that will put us in a better
position and if anything that happens
and when we get to the other side of
this awful pandemic what will happen is
we're going to continue to bring back
that core manufacturing we're going to
continue to put America first and we're
going to meet the challenges ahead
it's ridiculous to try to rewrite
history and pretend not the intelligence
that has been leaking and lying about
president Trump using talk about
disinformation using disinformation from
fake Russian sources to try to sabotage
President Trump before he got into
office and ever since they're trying to
rewrite the script now and say oh really
would been responsible for this heat
he gave them a clean bill of health
didn't he he said he believed President
Putin he'd looked into his eyes he
believed what he said when Putin had
denied any involvement in hacking into
American system Trump believed him he
gave him the free pass Democrats in the
media are giving themselves a free pass
for literally publishing Russian
disinformation for over three years
because guess what Hillary Clinton's
dossier was a bunch of Lies they knew it
was a bunch of lies and guess oh they
didn't care they leaked it anyway tried
to legitimize a false narrative against
the president making Russia way more
impressive than they clearly are this
hysterical narrative about collusion
that was always a lie and it's really
it's really disgusting that now after
wasting three years of media attention
and vet endless investigations taxpayers
hard-earned taxpayer dollars on this
madness now they're trying to say oh we
actually were warning about a pandemic
give me a break Adam Schiff didn't hold
any hearings on China which everyone
knew was the actual real threat not
Russia just perfect didn't make any
mistakes at all never met never
apologize it's all perfect is it this is
what you look at the results you look at
the results and you look at the moves
they've made they have adapted they've
made the best
decisions possible with the information
at the time and it has put us in an
incredible position much better than
many other countries and the rest of the
world thousands cases about four times
more than the next highest number yes
you believe China's numbers too right
you loved communist China's regime that
is clearly suppressing its Chinese its
Communist Chinese propaganda their
numbers and they want the world to blame
America for their own pandemic that they
unleashed on the world so you're doing
the work of Communists in China but
please go on use their numbers more and
more people don't believe the president
anymore on what he said about the
coronavirus do they latest NBC Wall
Street Journal poll only 36% of
respondents in the bulk say they
generally trust what Trump has said a
52% say they don't trust him
so you're not winning the trust battle
are you at they're lost their jobs
millions are under lockdown
you're gonna politicize it and say that
it's president Trump's fault for
shedding so which is it did he act too
slow was a racist or I say you'll say
President Trump is just the worst person
to ever have lived so give me a break
communist regime unleashed a pandemic
their cover-up and least a pandemic on
the world that the entire world
including Germany is having to clean up
so President Trump has done an amazing
job dealing with this and you're gonna
try to use hurting jobless Americans
against him he was cheerleading for the
Chinese he said China's been working
very hard to contain the virus the u.s.
greatly appreciates their efforts and
transparency
yeah China was lying to us at the time
yeah and it was also Obama's fault that
you didn't have a test is that right
well it was certainly it was certainly
Obama and Biden's fault that the
stockpile of n95 masks were depleted
would you agree with that don't up to me
to agree or disagree with it
Oh May he said many times he'd inherited
a broken
convenient that the obama-biden
administration which if as you claimed
everyone knew this pandemic was coming
why did they leave us completely empty
with the stockpiles of mass and other
critical supplies they knew that in 2009
there's a hearing with then-secretary
Health and Human Services Secretary
Kathleen Sebelius where she acknowledged
that the stockpiles were empty she
acknowledged that all of our medical
supplies were empty they had eight years
and they never did a single thing to
refill that stockpile so it's a failure
of government bureaucracies and onerous
regulations that have gotten that have
gotten in the way for far too long
president Trump wisely has unleashed the
private sector gotten rid of these
owners regulations working in
conjunction with the FDA with the CDC to
get Americans the resources they need
it's been an it has been an incredible
achievement and you know Monday Morning
Quarterback everything you want but the
fact remains President Trump is up there
every single day answering every single
question being transparent
unlike the Communists in China being
honest and okay for themselves I have to
leave it there thank you very much for
being on comforting sir thank you
[Music]
you